The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Ready?
So let me recap the
important lecture
from last time that gave
the framework that we'll
see in Chapter two
and Chapter three,
really a major
part of the course.
And our example was a line
of masses and springs.
So that's like, the first
example to start with.
And you remember,
there were three steps.
If we want to know how
much the masses displace
we have to get to the springs.
Difference in displacements gave
the stretching of the springs.
Then comes the material law,
Hooke's Law in this case,
with a matrix C that led to CAu.
And then finally,
those spring forces
are balanced by the
external forces.
That brought in A transpose.
So that's the
picture to look for.
And I just mention it again
because it's so central.
So we'll be doing
other examples of that.
But I wanted to stay with
springs and masses for today.
To do another type of problem.
A problem in which time enters.
A problem in which we're not
looking for the steady state.
But it's Newton's Law
is going to come in.
This is actually Newton's Law.
You recognize mass.
You recognize acceleration.
And the force on
the spring is -Ku.
So when -Ku, when the force
came over to that side,
that's the equation
we're looking at.
So it's like time-out
for a discussion
of the very important
subject of time derivatives.
How do I solve initial
value problems now?
So I have some
starting time, I'm
given u(0), the starting
position of the springs,
and I'm given the
velocity at zero.
So I'm given two facts at zero.
That's very different from
the steady state problem
where you're given stuff
around the boundary.
Here we're given
stuff at the start.
Initial values instead
of boundary values.
So what does this mean?
It means that maybe I pull
the springs down and I let go.
And what do they do?
They oscillate.
And you will have
studied this equation.
I hope you've seen
that equation.
Because I think of it as
the fundamental equation
of mechanics.
In fact, I've even
used those words.
The fundamental equation
of mechanical engineering.
Well, it's Newton's
Law for a system.
So the matrix M
now has two masses.
In this case, it would
be a two by two system.
The matrix M would
have two masses.
Suppose mass one may be like,
nine and mass two is one.
So copying what our problem
is we'd have a nine and a one
multiplying u_1'' and u_2''.
Can I use prime
for a derivative?
Rather than dots,
because I'm never
too sure if the dot
is there or not.
So prime I can see.
And then plus our Ku.
And actually you know what K
will look like for this system.
It's fixed-fixed.
Well, let me write down
what K would look like.
Just because we saw
it at the very end.
What it looks like if there
are spring constants, c_1, c_2,
and c_3.
Can I just remind you
what that will look like?
So this will multiply
u and give zero.
So the mass matrix is
diagonal in the problem.
That's, diagonal matrices, we
certainly expect to be easy.
Almost as easy as
the identity matrix
where we would have
two equal masses.
Here it's just that
little bit more general
with two different masses.
And in here, the kind of thing
that we created just at the end
of the last lecture was
something like c_1+c_2
on the diagonal and a -c_2
and a -c_2 and a c_2+c_3.
So c_2 for the middle
spring is the one
that's really there with its
full little element matrix,
c_2, -c2; -c_2, c_2.
The c_1 part is only
coming in at the top
because it's connected
to a fixed support.
And c_3 is only coming
in at the bottom.
Anyway, that's the matrix
K. This is the matrix M.
And how do we solve the problem?
You've seen before, and now
ADINA Professor Bathe's code
or any other code would offer,
like, two different ways.
One way is because we have
constant coefficients here
we can expect a pretty clean
formula for the answer.
And because we're growing,
we're oscillating in time,
things are happening in
time, we expect eigenvectors,
eigenvalues to come in.
Into that formula.
I think it's worth just
repeating that formula.
How do you approach it?
And then the second,
the really serious issue
is how do you solve
equation like this
or even more general,
time-dependent problems.
I mean this is what finite
element codes are created for.
How do you study
the crash of a car?
So this isn't quite the
equation for a car crash.
What would be different
in a car crash?
There's a short section
later in Chapter two
called the reality of
computational engineering.
And the reality is, cars crash,
people drop their cell phones.
And those are very difficult
problems to compute with.
And of course, absolutely
impossible to use eigenvectors
because, well they're
not linear at all.
Right?
If you crash two cars,
if you want to study,
everything's happening
in like, a hundredth
of a second or something.
But what's happening
there is highly non-linear
so it's very much
more complicated.
And you take thousands
of time steps
maybe within the crash time.
And you're going to use finite
differences or finite elements.
So this is a chance
to say something
about this special equation
for finite difference method.
It's really 18.086 that takes
up these questions seriously.
If I choose a finite
difference method.
See, the thing is with
finite differences
you've got many, many choices.
There's only one way
to go in step one.
Eigenvectors, this thing has
got eigenvectors, you find them,
you're in.
But for the much more
general, typical problems
that you'll be solving
the rest of your lives,
finite differences
or finite elements,
you've got lots of choices.
And the issues that come up
are the accuracy of the choice.
Centered differences
often gives you
that extra order of accuracy.
Stability is something
we have not seen yet.
So what does stability mean?
Stability means that as I follow
my difference equation forward
in time it stays near
the true equation.
You'll see by example.
So some methods are
more stable than others,
some are completely
unstable and unusable.
And then, of course,
the other condition,
another desired requirement,
is speed of calculation.
So these balance each other.
It's a beautiful subject.
And let me just open the
door to that subject today.
May I start with the
eigenvector solution.
How would I solve this
equation by eigenvectors?
Well again, I'm going to
look for special solutions.
So let me write that
equation down again.
Mu''+Ku=0.
I'm taking zero external force.
So the springs and masses
are just oscillating.
Their total energy won't
change, it's a closed system.
The kinetic plus the potential
energy will stay constant
and we can show why.
There's a lot in this section,
by the way, section 2.2.
More than I would be able
to do in the lecture.
But let me capture
the key ideas.
So one key idea is
the natural idea when
we have constant coefficients.
Look for special solutions.
So let me say look for special
solutions of the form--
well, let's keep in mind always
the simplest model of all.
Let me put it over here because
I'll focus on it particularly,
especially.
The simplest case would be u'',
with a mass normalized to one,
plus u equal 0.
Just a single equation.
So that's just a single spring.
Single mass.
So the mass is just
oscillating up and down.
And we all know that it's
going to oscillate up and down,
sines and cosines are
going to come into here.
In fact, we know
that the solution
to that would be, this
could have cosine, this
would have some
cos(t)'s and some-- u
could be a combination
of cos(t) and sin(t).
Right?
And the A and B would
be used to match the two
initial conditions.
So that's what we've
got in the scalar case.
This is one spring. n is one.
We don't have a matrix
here, just a number.
But that's our guide
to the matrix case.
So now what am I
going to look for?
I'm going to look for u(t).
I'll look for special
solutions of the form cos--
They'll go at
different frequencies.
So the frequency
has to be found.
So that's the time dependence.
And then some, if I'm
lucky all the springs
will be going together.
So this x-- Am I going
to use x for eigenvector?
I think so, yes.
Let's use x for eigenvector.
So this is a vector, this
is a constant vector.
And this gives the oscillation.
Let me just already
start with that.
I've got two
unknowns here, right?
Two things that
I'm free to choose.
I'm free to choose
the frequency omega
and I'm free to
choose this vector x.
And I've like,
separated out time.
The way we've been doing
it with an e^(lambda*t).
We used an e^(lambda*t).
So that was sort of right
for a first order equation.
Cosine is right for a second
order equation like this.
When is that a solution
to my equation?
May I just plug it in?
So I'm going to just plug it in?
Substitute is a better
word than plug in, right?
So shall I just plug it in?
So I get M times that
second derivative.
So the second
derivative of the cosine
is the cosine with a
minus, M omega squared.
Is that right?
Yes?
Times what?
So that's what came from
the time derivative.
Times cos times
this, cos(omega*t)x.
Two time derivatives brought
down a minus omega squared.
And the other part is just
K times u, cos(omega*t)x.
And that should be zero.
And this is supposed to
be a good solution that
works for all time.
This is what I want to be zero.
Do you see what's left?
Kx from here.
And putting that on the other
side, M omega squared x.
Can I write the omega squared
that way? omega squared Mx.
Then if that is satisfied
then the differential equation
is satisfied.
I've got a solution.
So I'm looking for K and
I'm looking for x and omega.
And by the way, I could
also have sin(omega*t) here.
As well as cosine just
the way over there.
Sines and cosines both possible.
So sin(omega*t)x.
It would be exactly the
same except that it'd be
a sin(omega*t) that
I'd be dividing out.
And again, I'd
come back to this.
This is key problem.
And do you see that somehow
here we have an eigenvector x
and an eigenvalue omega squared?
An eigenvalue omega
squared, right.
But there is one little twist.
It's not quite our standard
eigenvalue problem.
What's the extra guy
that's present in that box
that we don't usually see?
M. M is the new person
there, new thing.
The mass matrix.
Which, if all masses
where one, the mass matrix
would be the identity.
We would be back.
We would just have
our standard problem.
I just have to say a
word about the case
when the mass matrix is there.
It's still an
eigenvalue problem.
If you like, I can bring
M inverse over here.
I could write it as M inverse
K x equal omega squared x.
So I'm looking for the
eigenvalues of M inverse K.
That's really what I'm doing.
The eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of M inverse K.
But I'm always trying to be
like, aesthetically right.
And what's-- M inverse K has
just a little something wrong
with it.
Which is?
It's not symmetric.
If I take my matrix K, which
is beautifully symmetric,
and my M, which is
beautifully symmetric,
but when I do M inverse K,
do you see what'll happen?
The inverse of that
matrix will have a 1/9.
When I do M inverse*K, that
row will get divided by nine.
And the second row won't
change because I've got a one.
So it just like,
spoiled things a little.
You can deal with it.
But actually, in some way
it's better to keep it right.
And MATLAB is totally
okay with that.
So MATLAB would use the command
eig -- and other systems too --
of K, M. Just tell
MATLAB the two matrices.
Then it solves that problem.
It will print out the,
well if you just typed eig,
it would print out
the eigenvalues.
If you ask it for the
eigenvector matrix,
it'll print those too.
So that has the grand name
generalized eigenvalue problem.
Generalized because
it's got an M in there.
I don't know if you've met
these problems where there could
be an M. It's just a
natural, and it's not really
a big deal, particularly when M
is a positive diagonal matrix.
It's not a big deal at all.
It's the same codes essentially
finding the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
So suppose we have them.
We expect n positive
eigenvalues,
and those'll be
the omega squareds.
And each one comes
with its eigenvector.
And complete set,
everything is good.
We're talking about symmetric
positive definite matrices.
Notice that K is
positive definite.
That was what our whole
last weeks have been about.
And M is obviously
positive definite.
So it's a complete--
it's a perfect set-up
for the eigenvalue problem.
I just want to think
through the final step.
After we find the eigenvalues,
lambda, the omega squareds,
then we know the omegas and
we find the eigenvectors, x,
how do you write the answer?
So what have I done so far?
I've looked for some
special solutions.
And I will find them.
So I've found these omegas.
They can go with sines or
cosines, I found the x's.
Now what's the general solution?
If I have these solutions
to my great equation
there, what's the
general solution? u(t).
So this would be
the big picture.
What can I do in
linear equations?
Linear combinations.
That's what linear algebra is
all about, linear combinations.
So I could take a linear
combination of these cosines,
so cos(omega_1*t)x_1.
So that would be
a solution coming
from the first eigenvector and
eigenvalue, or the square root,
times any constant.
And then, of course,
I could have a b_1.
I'll use b's for the sines.
(omega_1*t), x_1.
So that's just like that.
But it's used the sines, which
would also solve the equation.
And then all the
way down to x_n's.
Right?
So I've got 2n.
2n simple solutions. n cosines
times eigenvectors and n sines
times those same eigenvectors.
Why do I want 2n?
I've got 2n constants then to
choose, the a's and the b's.
And how do I choose them?
What's the next step?
Using eigenvectors, maybe I just
mention again the three steps.
The three step method.
Step one: find a's and b's.
Oh, now you have to
answer my question.
Where are the a's and
b's going to come from?
What's going to determine
these 2n constants,
the a's and the b's?
The initial
conditions, of course.
We've got two initial
conditions, this is a vector.
We're talking about
a system here.
I've got position
of both masses.
I've got the initial
velocity of both masses.
And the a's, they come
from, because the a's go
with the cosines and so they're
going to be the ones associated
with u(0), will give this.
Will give a combination-- Will
give the a's. u(0) will be
a_1*x_1 + a_n*x_n.
This is at t=0.
So I'm using the
initial conditions.
u(0) is a combination
of those eigenvectors.
So this is from the
initial conditions.
And the b's of course are going
to come from u'(0), the initial
velocity, because
they go with sines.
So sines start at zero but
they have an initial velocity.
So that's step one.
That finds the constants.
It splits the problem
into these normal modes.
It finds how much
of each eigenvector
is in there at the start.
Step two?
So it's really worth
seeing these three steps
because they just repeat and
repeat for all applications
of eigenvalues.
Step two is what?
Step two is follow each of
these guys forward in time.
Follow them to any time.
What does that mean?
That means just put in
the cosines and the sines.
So the a's go to a*cos(omega*t).
So I'm just saying what
happens to those coefficients.
Each one.
Let's see. a_i, say, goes to
a_i is multiplied by the cosine.
And the b's, b_i's go
to b_i*sin(omega_i*t).
So now we followed the
coefficients forward in time.
And step three?
The final step is?
So here, we're
following each one.
So the pattern is
always the same one.
Take your starting
conditions, split them up
into eigenvectors.
Follow each eigenvector.
And then step three is?
Reassemble.
Put them back together.
Step three is the solution.
u at that later time t is
a_1*cos(omega_1*t)x_1.
And b_1*sin(omega_1*t)x_1.
Those are the two guys
that are reflecting
the fundamental mode.
And then we have a_2's and b_2's
multiplied by cosines and sines
and times x_2 and so on.
Put the pieces together.
So it's split the
initial conditions,
follow each
eigenvector, reassemble.
It's the heart of
Fourier methods,
it's the heart of
using eigenvectors.
And there's a little code in
the book that does exactly that.
So let's just pause a moment.
This was the
eigenvector solution.
And now I want to talk
about computational science.
For which this
problem is a model,
but the problem has probably got
more complications and things
change in time, whatever.
This was an exact solution.
That's more than we hope
for in real computations.
We hope for accuracy, but we
don't hope for 100% accuracy
unless we have this
exact model problem.
So we use finite differences.
Ready for finite differences?
So this is method one, which
allows you to understand
the model problem.
And now comes method two,
which allows you to compute
much more, many more problems.
And if I do it just for
this, let me come back
to just this model.
One spring and one mass.
Shall we start the mass at rest?
Let me make that the answer.
I want that to be the answer.
So I'm going to start with u(0)
to be zero-- to be one, right?
I'm going to start with u(0)
to be one and u'(0) to be zero.
Because the cosine starts
at one and its derivative
starts at zero.
Apologies that this is
such a simple model.
I'm just pulling this
this mass down and let go.
I just pull it down an
amount one, I let go,
it oscillates forever.
How do I draw the
motion of a single mass?
A picture is
important and we have
to think what's in the picture.
So I think the picture should
be, maybe u in this direction
and maybe u' in this direction.
So it's the u, u' plane.
The position-velocity plane.
Sometimes called
the phase plane.
I'll just write that
word down, phase plane.
And what will be
our picture here?
It starts there, right? u(0) is
one, no velocity, starts there.
Oh, and then it
just follows cos(t).
And of course, I
know what u' is.
If u is cos(t), u' is -sin(t).
Let me put that somewhere where
my picture won't run over it,
up here maybe. u' is -sin(t).
Help me out.
If as time increases,
I follow this point,
the x-coordinate is cos(t).
The y-coordinate is -sin(t).
It's a circle.
So I just buzz along it,
because of that minus sign,
the circle goes this way around.
It's a unit circle.
Goes on forever.
And actually cos squared
plus sine squared
is one, of course, that's why
it's a circle of radius one.
And that represents the
total energy actually.
I'm trying to draw a circle.
Actually how would you get
your computer to draw a circle?
I'm thinking not
just one circle.
I want to refresh it.
I mean, I want to
follow this in time.
So I want to draw, I want to
follow a point around a circle.
Well I suppose what
you would do would be
to ask it to plot those points.
That's not allowed.
I want you to follow the
solution to the equation.
I want to take that equation
whose exact solution is
a circle and I want to use
finite differences in time.
So I'm going to
take finite steps.
Of course that's what
the computer has to do.
The computer will
take finite steps.
So I'd be very happy if
those finite steps keep me
on the circle.
And I'd be even happier if
it came around exactly right
at 2pi but it's not going to.
I want finite differences.
I want to replace that
differential equation
by finite differences.
And when we do this
equation, we're
practically doing that
one at the same time.
So this model will be fine.
So I'm going to introduce finite
differences for this equation.
And everybody,
we've been talking
about how to replace
second derivatives
by second differences.
So that looks good.
Let me write down,
maybe I can write down
three or four possible
finite differences.
For u'' I think I'll write
down u_(n+1) - 2u_n + u_(n-1).
That's the second
difference that
replaces the second
derivative, divided by what?
What do you think goes
in the denominator now?
Square of what?
Yeah, now what's the right name?
It's going to be
something squared.
What do I put down there?
The step size.
I don't want to call
it delta x, right?
What should I call that?
Delta t would be
natural, delta t.
Or h, I could again use h
just to have a shorthand.
That's my second difference.
It's centered, it's
the natural choice.
And not the only
choice, by the way.
Oh.
If I'm an astronomer or
like, Professor Wisdom here.
So he followed
Pluto around, right?
And discovered that Pluto
wasn't a planet, right?
He discovered that
the motion of Pluto
was not like, regular
like the Earth.
I think the Earth is regular.
But Pluto has chaotic motion.
So it does crazy stuff.
Right.
Well we're looking for very
periodic, circular motion here.
So what I was going to
say, Professor Wisdom, he
would sneer at this
second differences, right?
I mean, as we'll see that's
got decent accuracy, but not
accuracy that would
allow you to follow
Pluto for 100 million years.
But it'll do for us.
We're not going 100
million years here.
So now comes -u.
Now, question.
I'm taking this,
the u term and I'm
putting it on the other side.
So mass is one.
Acceleration is this.
The force is -u.
Now comes the big question.
For -u, do I use
the newest value?
Do I use the middle value?
Or do I use the oldest value?
Or some combination?
If I want high
accuracy, oh, then I
go way up in these
differences and I
find tricky combinations
that get me above first
and second order accuracy.
But let's not go there.
So I've got to make
one of those choices.
And that choice is going
to decide, so I mean,
this is a choice
you have to make
when you have such a problem.
Where are you going
to evaluate this?
I guess one choice
jumps out as natural.
What would you think of doing?
Well how many would do that one?
So those are people, that's
the conservative choice,
the stable.
And then, how many
would do this?
Yeah, you would do that, right.
I would call that
the leapfrog choice.
Somehow, this
second difference is
leaping over this middle point.
So that would be
the leapfrog method.
And then if I use a very
low-- to use the first value
would be-- So my point is those
are three different choices.
And each one has these
questions of accuracy.
The middle one will be more
accurate because it's centered.
Each one has a
question of stability.
Ah, you don't see stability yet.
So that's the point of the
rest of the lecture is to see.
What is this stability question?
The issue of speed, speed
would be, this is the slow one.
Because it involves, I have
to bring u_(n+1) over there.
And if I've got a system
of equations and then I,
it would take me some time.
This would be called
an implicit method.
The new u_(n+1) is only given
implicitly because it's showing
up on the right-hand side.
I've got to move it
over to the left.
If it's non-linear I've
got a system to solve.
It's safer, but more expensive.
But this would be
the natural choice.
I want to get eigenvalues
into this picture.
So I'm going to do the
step we often do when
we see a second order equation.
That is, reduce it to two
first order equations.
Can I do that and
see the same thing?
So what would be my two
first order equations.
My unknowns will be u and u'.
So it'll be first order,
the derivative of u and u'.
Shall I call it v for velocity?
Let me write down, I don't
need to write this fancy.
The two equations will
be, u'=v. And v' is what?
So u'=v sort of told me what
v was. v is the velocity,
the time derivative of du/dt.
And now the derivative
of the velocity, now that
should reflect my true equation.
So this is all
coming from u''+u=0.
So v' is what? v' is u''.
Do I want -u there?
Yeah, that's my equation.
v', which is u'', is -u.
Good.
That's my system.
So I have a matrix here.
I have a two by two system with
a matrix [0, 1; -1, 0] I guess.
So while thinking about
difference methods-- So this,
I was thinking about a
second order equation.
I went right to it.
Here I'm thinking about
a first order system.
A lot of problems come
in first order systems.
Gas dynamics comes
as a big first order
system for those components
of mass, momentum, energy,
typically five non-linear
equations in gas dynamics.
I mean, that's a very,
very serious problem,
how to solve those.
Here we've got a much
simpler model problem,
linear, constant coefficients.
But what do we do?
Can I propose three
possibilities here?
And actually they are identical
to these three possibilities.
If I just switch over
to a first order system.
So possibility one_
Possibility one is that u_(n+1)
and v_(n+1)-- So the
u_(n+1) would be,
how do I model that equation?
u_(n+1) is u_n + delta t*v_n.
That would be a natural-- Right?
Let me just pause
there, because that's
meant to be the natural
forward difference.
So I replaced u' by
u_(n+1)-u_n over delta t.
And I replaced v by
the value I know.
And do you know whose name
is associated with that?
I'm almost going
to say his name.
It's just, I replace a
differential equation
by a difference
equation where each step
I just could figure
out what the slope is
and I go along a straight line.
Delta t further along.
Do you know his name?
Euler, Euler, right.
It's Euler's method.
The very first method
you would think of.
Right?
So I'm doing the
same for v. This
is my position I've reached.
So Euler's method
is replace this
by over delta t equals -u_n.
v_(n+1)-v_n over
delta t equals -u_n.
So this is Euler's idea.
Predict the new value
by a forward difference
starting from where the slope
of the line is this old one.
That's the first difference
method you would think of.
So now if I multiply up by delta
t I have a minus delta t*u_n.
Good time to pay attention.
This is forward Euler.
Forward Euler.
The time step, you
follow the derivative,
what the derivative is
at the start of the step.
You follow it for a little step.
Ah, let me draw what
the thing would do.
Shall I draw what
forward Euler will do?
So we're here.
And what's our first step?
Our first step.
So we're starting at v
is zero at the start.
So u won't change in one step.
But u is one, so v will go down.
I think the first step
will take us there.
That point was (1, 0).
And I think the second
step, u came from the zero,
so it'll still be a one.
And v came from a
zero, but minus delta.
I think it'll just be 1-delta t.
It's left the circle, of course.
And what do you think happens
when I do 1,000 steps?
This is two lines in MATLAB.
Just write those equations
for the next u coming
from the previous u starting
at (1, 0) and see what happens.
And what do you think?
It's going to sort of go around.
I mean, it's a reasonable--
Euler wasn't dumb.
Anything true here is the
fact that Euler was not dumb.
He had a bunch of ideas.
This wasn't his greatest.
But it's the starting
point of any,
if you have to code some
complicated problem,
start with Euler, forward Euler.
What'll happen?
It'll spiral out.
Exactly.
And if I was an
eigenvalue person,
I guess which I probably am,
I would look at the, there's
some matrix here that's finding
the new u, v from the old u,
v. Maybe we can
even find out, write
above what that matrix is.
The new u, v come
from the old u, v,
well there is the
identity matrix.
Here is a delta t.
And here is our minus delta t.
That would be my matrix.
That's the forward Euler matrix.
The growth matrix for
forward Euler is that.
Now what do you think about
its eigenvalues before?
Spiral out was the right answer.
If delta t is small it'll
stay close to the circle,
but it'll spiral out from it.
So if we were following a
planet, it would just be off.
So I can't immediately,
well you could almost
see the eigenvalues
of this matrix.
What's the determinant
of that matrix?
What's the determinant of G?
I'm just asking you
to think through.
You see a matrix like this.
You wonder about its eigenvalues
so you take the determinant.
And what do you get?
One, something bigger
than one or less than one?
Bigger.
So that tells me what?
Since the determinant is the
product of lambda_1*lambda_2,
whatever those guys are, at
least one of those eigenvalues
is bigger than one.
This has an
eigenvalue, actually,
the actual eigenvalues of
this happen to be one from
the identity matrix and
then this guy is what was
our example of an imaginary
eigenvalue, i*delta t.
Bigger than one
in absolute value.
It goes out.
So that's forward Euler
corresponding to that choice.
Can I change to a second,
to Euler's other choice?
And you can guess
what its name is.
Instead of forward
Euler it's going to be?
Backward Euler.
Euler said, if you don't like
it, I've got another one.
And what will happen then?
Backward Euler is going to
use, instead of the old value,
it will use the new values here.
So these differences,
you see that this is now
a backward difference?
So I'm at time n+1.
I'm at the new time.
And this goes back from that.
So this is at the new time and
this is a difference backward.
And what happens now?
Well, we could follow
backward Euler.
We could follow its first step.
What would its first step be?
u_n+u_1.
This is-- No, I can't follow
that first step so easily.
Help me out by just
making a guess.
What do you think
backward Euler does?
It spirals in.
Right, the cover of the book
has forward Euler, I think,
is on the cover of the textbook.
Spiraling out in the front.
But maybe the back cover
also has Euler spiraling in.
So here is backward Euler.
And after I take
a bunch of steps
it comes back somewhere
there, but it's spiraled in.
No good.
Have we got one minute
for the good method?
You're guessing
that it's this one?
How does that work?
Actually, it's pretty neat.
So my question is, where
do I evaluate these guys?
So this is like
forward and backward.
The u equation, so I
know u_n and v_n, right?
Everybody with me?
I've got to time in,
I know u_n and v_n,
the position and velocity,
approximately at point n.
And I want to go n+1.
What I know is v_n.
So that's great.
But what's going to change here?
Now I know u_(n+1) from
the first equation.
What shall I do, where
shall I evaluate u
in the second equation?
At n+1.
Why not?
I know it already
from the first step,
from the forward step
with this equation.
I've taken u forward.
So I'll use that forward
value of u in the v equation.
So it's forward and
backward at the same time.
And the net result if I go
back from my system of two
first order equations back
to one second order equation,
I'll find the centered guy.
And what do you think happens
with that centered difference?
I think MATLAB would
have to show it.
And look in Section
2.2 for the picture
that shows the leapfrog method.
So what do you think?
I'm having to depend
on my memory now.
It stays almost on the circle.
I think it maybe, it stays
very close to the circle.
And comes back almost at the
right time, but not exactly.
Because we have an error here.
No, we haven't got
the real equation.
We've got a difference equation.
So maybe that's
the point to say.
When you start with a
differential equation
you've got various choices.
Backward is actually safer.
Probably for a car crash.
No, actually I think
for a car crash
they would use
forward differences
because they have
to take so many.
Let me check on that.
But for our problem, this
one, leapfrog is the winner.
Actually, if anybody
does computation
in computational
chemistry, I mean
that's a subject that uses
giant supercomputers to follow
molecular dynamics, to follow
what molecules are doing
at high speed, very high speed.
So this, there's a giant
number multiplying that u.
And they use leapfrog method.
I'll say a little
more Friday if I can
about this general subject,
because it's so important.